hi i'm mike coleman a developer advocate
here at google cloud
in this video i want to walk you through
how you can use google cloud's migrate
for anthos
to move existing linux workloads from
virtual machines to containers in just a
few steps
this video builds on an earlier one
introducing migrate paranthos
if you haven't watched that video yet
definitely go check it out
as this one assumes you perform the
prerequisites we outlined there
building on what you learned in the
first video let's jump into an actual
migration
as a brief recap migrate for anthos has
three primary components
the discovery tool assesses how
successful a migration of a given
application might be
the processing cluster is a kubernetes
cluster that is used to examine the
source vm
and create the migration plan as well as
execute the actual migration
and finally mig ctl a command line tool
like coop ctl
for interacting with the processing
cluster we'll do most of our work today
in the google cloud console
but i will show you a bit of mix etl and
again to quickly recap
a migration generally consists of the
following steps
first create a google cloud project set
up the necessary service accounts
and enable the appropriate apis then you
create a migration processing cluster
after that choose and qualify your
target workload
then you define your migration source
create a migration plan
and adjust that plan to ensure it meets
your needs
after that you create the actual
deployment artifacts
and then finally you can deploy the
newly containerized application
the first two steps were covered in the
previous video so we'll start by
discussing
choosing the right workload there are
some applications that are well suited
for migration
and some that are not linux applications
that are a good fit for migration using
migrate for anthos include the following
application architectures
web and application servers business
logic middleware for example
tomcat multivm multi-tier stacks for
example
lamp small and medium-sized databases
like mysql and postgres
in addition applications best suited for
migration with migrate for anthos have
the following operational
characteristics
they have a low duty cycle and bursty
workloads
they're always on with low load services
or deployment
testing and training lab environments in
general
most linux workloads are compatible with
migration however there are some types
of workloads that are not really
recommended
these would include high performance and
large in-memory databases
vms with special kernel drivers for
example kernel mode
nfs apps with dependencies on specific
hardware
and software with licenses tied to
certain hardware id registration
for this demo i'm using a java
application housed in a vm which also
has
a postgres database so i have a good
feeling that this application is an
appropriate candidate to migrate but how
can i be sure
well we have a utility for that the
migrate for anthos discovery tool
the discovery tool has two parts the
first is a collection script that runs
on the source vm
and analyzes the running application
the analysis script then looks at that
information gathered from the collection
phase
and gives us a score of 1 to 10 on the
likelihood of a successful migration
you can run your analysis script on a
centralized server allowing you to batch
process
collected data so let's jump into our
demo and look at the discovery tool
which i've already installed on the
source vm running on google compute
engine
you can consult the migrate franco
stocks for info on how to install the
tool
before we look at the discovery tool i
wanted to take a quick overview
of the sample application we're working
with which is the symbol bank app
so i'm going to go ahead and come down
here and click sign in
and what you're going to see here is a
typical banking application we're
looking at the ledger view here
i can come up and i can click send
payment i can choose
another user from the drop down we'll
use alice here i'm going to send her
a hundred dollars and we're going to
click send and you can see the ledger
update
so everything is working the way we
expect it to let's look a little bit how
that application is deployed on the back
end
the application is actually made up of a
combination of kubernetes services
and then a monolithic service running in
a virtual machine so
on the kubernetes side we have four
services running they handle everything
from managing the accounts database
uh to the the web front end we just
interacted with to that drop down list
that we saw
where we can pull up associated accounts
that the main user has
we come into here this is our vm that
we're going to migrate and that's the
ledger service so everything you saw
there that dealt with the ledger
that is handled here so how do we update
the ledger uh check balances those sort
of things the other thing is that this
monolith
includes the database the ledger
database so there's an accounts database
and a ledger database and the ledger
database
lives inside of this vm so when we're
done we're going to have migrated this
vm
into a kubernetes service so let's get
started with that
so here i am i've ssh into that ledger
monolith service vm
and as i mentioned before i've already
installed the my great franthos
discovery tool
so what we want to do here is let's take
a look at what that's comprised of you
have the collect script and the analysis
script
so we're going to go ahead and run that
collect script first so let me run that
and that's going to produce a tar file
here and we're going to go ahead
and then run the analysis script against
that tar file
so we'll go ahead and run that
and then that gives us a csv file let's
cat out the
contents of that file
so this is a little hard to read on the
screen so what i've done is i've
actually taken
and moved that csv onto my local machine
and loaded it up into a google sheet
there's a lot of information here i'm
only going to point out a couple of
things
first our fit score is a 9 and that is
right here
so we've got a 9 out of 10 and that
means it's a great fit
with none to very little manual work
based on the glossary here
the other thing i want to point out is
that we do have a postgres database
in the vm that the fit tool discovered
and we'll have to deal with that during
our migration
but with a score of nine we should feel
pretty good that we should be able to
migrate this application
with very little effort so the next step
is to actually create a migration source
so we're gonna do that by moving back
here
in the cloud console and we're gonna go
to anthos
migrate to containers remember we've
already set up our processing cluster we
did that in our last
video so the processing cluster is right
here so now we're going to create a
source
so we'll come in and we'll say add
source and we're going to select our
processing cluster
click next we're going to go ahead and
give this source a name
and it's going to come from compute
engine remember it can come from vmware
or
aws or azure as well but in this case
we're using compute engine
we'll click next as in the first video
we
created one service account to actually
let us install the components on the
processing cluster
and now we're going to create a second
service account that lets us deal with
that compute engine as a source so we
will
put the compute viewer and the compute
storage admin roles onto this service
account
we'll click next and we'll go ahead and
add the source
so we come back here we have our source
all ready for us to go
next let's move on and create our
migration now one thing to note is that
before i can actually migrate a vm i
have to stop it which i've already done
i've gone into the
google cloud console and i've stopped
that ledger service vm so it's not
running any longer
with that i would come in here now and i
click create migration
i take the migration name and i'll give
it a name here
we'll come down we'll select the source
that we just created
linux operating system and the virtual
machine id
is ledger monolith dash
service so right there and we're going
to migrate both the
image and data in this case that
monolith vm has postgres running in it
so we need both the
application code and the data so let's
click create migration
this will take a couple minutes so i'll
fast forward the video and i'll rejoin
you when it's done
our migration plan has been generated so
the next step here is now to make sure
that migration plan is accurate for
what we want to do so we can come here
to options and we can review and edit
the migration plan
now i know one thing i'm going to need
to change is
down here under data volumes i need to
go ahead and tell it that i want to use
the postgresql folder right so we're
going to point it at that postgres
subdirectory because remember we have
that database running
there in our monolithic vm so with that
i can save this
and generate my artifacts so let's click
save and generate artifacts
and it will save it and it'll start
generating the artifacts again
this will take a couple of minutes so
i'll pause the video and i'll rejoin you
when it finishes
so the migration is completed and our
artifacts have been generated i can
click on the link of the migration here
and click on the artifacts tab and you
can get a list of all of them so we have
a docker file but
the docker image has actually already
been created and uploaded to container
registry for us so we don't need to do
anything with that
what we really care about is this
deployment spec now there's a couple
ways you can grab the deployment spec
or any of the artifacts for that matter
one is they're stored in
a storage bucket up on google cloud
storage
and you could download them from here
the other way to do it is to use mig ctl
the command line utility and that's what
we're gonna do
so i'm gonna move over into cloud shell
and i'm gonna issue a mig
ctl migration get artifacts command
and that's gonna download the artifacts
for me
so let me go ahead here and i'll list
out the deployment spec.yaml just to
verify it got downloaded
and that's a standard kubernetes yaml
file for deploying the service and some
other stuff
we're not going to spend a lot of time
going into that but what we are going to
do now is actually apply it
now the processing cluster is different
from the production cluster where i run
my applications so i need to actually
authenticate into that production
cluster so let me go ahead and
issue the gcloud command to authenticate
into my production cluster
and we will list out the nodes just to
make sure i have the right cluster
and i do so the next step is to actually
just do
a kubectl minus f apply
and apply the deployment spec
and that's going to create a stateful
set it's going to create a service
a persistent volume and a persistent
volume claim the persistent volume and
the persistent volume claim will be used
to handle that postgres database we
migrated over from our monolith vm
the next thing we need to do is ensure
all of the services can find each other
the symbol bank app does this through a
set of configuration variables
currently the variables associated with
the ledger service are pointing to the
compute engine
internal dns name of the ledger monolith
vm
which has the format of instance name
dot c
dot project id dot internal which you
can see right here
i'm going to swap those out for the
kubernetes service name
which is simply ledger monolith service
and if i list my kubernetes services you
can see that service listed right here
so the next thing to do is actually
apply that config map so those new
service
mappings take place so we'll apply the
config map here
next let's go ahead and delete all the
existing pods
and that will force them to pick up the
new mappings when they
regenerate and after that what we're
going to do
is we're going to list our services so
we can grab the ip address
of our front end and check out and make
sure the application's still working as
expected so i'll copy this
and i'm going to paste it up here into
my browser so the symbol bank the app
has loaded let's sign in again
so we're signed in here's the ledger
let's go into a send payment to alice
again let's give her 250
this time and we'll click send
and we can see the ledger is updated so
our application is working exactly as we
expected to after a successful migration
so there you have it in this video you
learned about using migrate for anthos
to move linux workloads into containers
including how to assess your application
create the migration plan
execute the migration and deploy your
newly containerized application
be sure to like and subscribe because
we'll be posting subsequent videos in
this series
to cover topics such as best practices
for evaluating your application
how to migrate windows workloads and
more to get started with migrate4anthos
today visit
slash cloud.google.com slash anthos
[Music]
you